I do want to talk about the end of Alexa
and Katy because it's asking on Netflix
so first of all how are you feeling
saying goodbye to the show to this
character
it's been such a big part of your life I
would imagine for the past few years yes
I am secretly hoping that we do one more
thing together you think that's possible
I don't know I mean I would love to do
like one more movie and just like then
really say goodbye and be over with I
had a very hard time saying goodbye we
are a big family like it's not even we
were like he's still our really big
family and he works so well together
Isabel was an amazing Katie she is an
amazing Katie and just she's an amazing
person too I learned so much from her
and I learned something too Tiffany and
Eddie and even Finn who's like I don't
know he's 11 now everyone was just so
open and it was just such a safe place
to work and just be free and creative I
do hope that we do something in the
future I'm hoping for it I don't know
but I'm hoping I'm putting it out into
the universe that we work together one
more time and I do want to come back to
that cause I do have some legs you know
possible questions okay but I want to
ask about the ending because we see
Alexa and Katie sort of go off to
college and do their own thing and then
the last moments are really them
reuniting
how did you feel about where they ended
up I honestly was a little shocked like
when I heard that that was gonna be the
ending I was like wait what what do you
mean but I mean it just that shows the
friendship between the two
you know Alexa was like no this is your
dream go like and and even when they are
apart they still come back together and
it's like nothing changed it was sad to
see them part but you also see like that
friendship is still there and they're
gonna love each other no matter what is
there anything that you would have
changed just because he said you were
shocked I mean if I were to change that
I would have had them go to the same
school together yeah but that wouldn't
have been a lexan Katie that would have
been like a version that we all make up
in our head like in certain situations
and scenarios in real life but that
wouldn't have been the friendship
between them yeah yeah but were those
last few days like on set for youguys
girl oh girl most lot of Tears yeah it
was really hard I that's the most I've
ever cried on a set or maybe in general
I it was yeah table read was really hard
just crying crying and rehearsals you
know it was so hard to do these scenes
it was so hard ah but it was really
beautiful because that just shows how
much we all cared about this show I feel
like we saw Alexa and Katie going
through so many moments and like the ups
and the downs and their friendship and
in their lives their favorite moment
that you had or like a favorite scene
that you shot I think one of my
favorites was the SAT episode and when
she has a panic attack yeah because I
actually have really bad anxiety and I
actually have panic attacks so filming
now scene with Isabel it was she did
such an amazing job on it kind of the
same thing with cancer like anxiety
they're not saying like oh it's a scary
thing like
you should be careful of this like it's
just like no like this happens and this
is what you can do to help I think
that's one of my favorite scenes that
we've had through the entire series how
do you handle things when you have an
anxiety attack or when you're feeling
that way I try to distract myself my my
boy my boyfriend is there for a lot of
them because we live together but he'll
just like he'll just like you know rub
my back and be like it's okay just
breathe and he'll distract me by like
asking me questions I mean he was
actually on the show right your
boyfriend yes he was yes what is it like
to work with him in that capacity I
actually really loved working with him
he is I mean he's like my significant
other I've been with him for a very long
time and he makes it very easy for me
because even like will do self tapes
together but again he helps me bring
something out in my acting I feel like
he's great to work with and I hope that
we hope that we get to do it again
sometime you said that you live together
is it did you guys move in during
quarantine or like pre quarantine and
how has that sort of been for the
relationship well I mean we did we
quarantine together and I was basically
living here and I was psychotic I'm
surprised he's still with me Wow no but
we were kind of joking about that that
we were like oh you know this is the
ultimate test like you know if we want
to have a future together this is really
the test like can we do it yeah and I
actually like officially moved in like a
couple days ago but I've been here for
the last couple months so but it's nice
it's you know it's nice not having to
pack a bag anymore and bring it to this
place or vice versa lots of dogs too so
it's nice to just all be together our
little furry family not to like talking
about this too much but you guys did
break up for a little bit right and then
you got back together yes yes we did and
I actually dated somebody else what
happened with that or how did you didn't
make you almost realize but like you
missed him or how to network I mean look
I things happen when
you're in a really long relationship and
when you're really really young and my
last relationship he was great he it was
actually me I was I was I was the bad
guy you learn a lot from everything any
relationship that you're in whether it's
good or bad or whether it was just like
I don't know but you definitely learn a
lot and yes I realized like okay I'm not
over things but yeah I think every
relationship is a learning experience
going back to the show you said that you
do want to do something else whether it
be a movie or working with a cast in
some capacity do you think there's room
for a spin off because of the way that
things were left I don't know you know
there are always jokes about we always
joked on set about a spin-off with Lucas
and Spencer but I think that was I I
don't know I think I think there's
always room for spin-offs I just think
it comes down to whether the cast wants
to do it or not I would love to do a
movie and maybe it's just like oh you
know Alexa and Katie go to New York like
I don't know something something like
just fun and yeah before I let you go is
there anything that you want to say to
your fans of the show who have like
stuck with you for all these seasons and
they're probably sad to say goodbye
until maybe a possible movie happens
just what do you want to say to them
well I am sad as well I am just as sad
if not more sad than all the fans who
have supported us all these years
and again I'm just so grateful that I
was able to be Alexa for you guys for so
long and I am so good for that like
we're number four on Netflix right now
and that's because of you guys that's
that's you know you guys are the reason
why we had a show for so long and
just thank you and I hope that we get to
see each other again as alexei gave
[Music]